دخان المعارك يتواصل صعوده من مقر القياده
العامه للجيش السوداني مع استمرار المعارك
في محيط المقر للمقر اهميه مركزيه فهو يقع
وسط العاصمه الخرطوم ويتكون من عده مباني
تدار من خلالها الجهات العسكريه والامنيه
في السودان هذه الاهميه سبب تركز القتال
بشكل كبير حول مقر القياده ففيه مباني
قياده كل من القوات البريه والبحريه
والجويه وقياده الاستخبارات العسكريه
ووزاره الدفاع كما يضم المقر ايضا عده
مباني مهمه منها مبنى المخابرات يوم
الخميس شهد احتدام المعارك حول القياده
العامه وخاصه في شارع المطار القريب من
المنطقه مع تواصل معارك الكر والفر وتراوح
القتال بين تصعيد وتهدئه غربا من هذا
المقر جرت اشتباكات في محيط القصر
الجمهوري وسط العاصمه السودانيه وتحدثت
وسائل اعلام محليه عن تكثيف قوات الدعم
السريع انت شارها بمدينه الخرطوم بحري
وتحديدا في حله حمد المطله على القصر
الرئاسي على الجانب الاخر من النيل الازرق
ومع اقتراب المعارك من اتمام اسبوعها
الاول يستمر تضارب المعلومات وظهور
تصريحات واخرى مضاده بين طرفي النزاع في
السودان دون اتضاح الصوره بشكل اكبر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات